severe sanctions reportedly unlikely for
the Patriots that comes from the
Washington Post and the investigation
likely to end this week now look the
bottom line is that there was a member
of the Patriots video crew that was in
the press box for the Browns Bengals
game right that was videotaping the
sidelines of the Bengals and there is
video of the sidelines of the Bengals
but the Patriots have acknowledged and
number one that it was a violation of
the rules but number two there's no
connection whatsoever to the football
operations this wasn't part of football
operations it wasn't intended to be
anything that was gonna be used for an
advantage and Chris the one last step in
this process needs to be an effort by
the NFL to ensure that there is no
overlap between the video crew and
football operations directly or
indirectly and that means looking at
text messages emails phone records to
ensure that they're telling the truth
here not because anybody thinks they're
lying right but I think you have to you
have to verify that that is actually the
truth before you make a final decision
you can't just take anyone at their word
in a situation like this because there
was a violation of the rules yeah no I
get you they need to verify it too just
to again maybe you know just back the
haters of the world of the New England
Patriots off who think there was
cheating again and they don't want to
hear anything different they just oh
that's it I don't need to hear anymore
the story the Patriots are cheaters no
that's not the case I mean hey listen
the first thing I want to say Mike is
whoever's in charge of the video
Department I mean I you know for lack of
it I don't want to see anybody get fired
but for lack of a better phrase what an
idiot I mean that's the first thing I
want to say because for you you have
some you know wherewithal to understand
who you're who you're working for the
history the scope of what's around that
organization and you're wearing Patriots
stuff in a press box and you're filming
a sideline like hey you would think
somebody in that department would have
gone hey guys you know there's a little
history here so let's be delicate and
let's not cause any problems or start
rumors or anything like that and then
secondly Mike I mean this is where you
and I got into an argument yesterday a
little bit I mean yeah I just don't
think the Patriots football part is has
anything to do with this
Bill's one of the most brilliant guys
I've ever seen been around anybody you
talk to would say the same thing I don't
think he just sent people out in the
clear a day who he doesn't know and I
was like hey film their sideline and
I'll trust you to do it right and when
you come back you can give me all the
answers you know that that just seemed a
little preposterous to me there's a
subtlety to it though that I think
potentially could operate where people
below Bill Belichick do these things
without telling him we don't know how
Ernie Addams gets his information
maybe Ernie Addams is involved in some
way we don't know what the hell Arnie
Adams even does so my point is in order
to confirm that there is no connection
the NFL needs to see whether or not
there are any communication the patrons
need to be transparent and honest and
complete in any records they make
available to confirm that this crew of
Yahoo's who was at the Browns Bengals
game has no connection in any way shape
or form right so what goes on with
football operations now here's another
angle to it as well yeah and this is one
of the problems that arises from the
Patriots reputation because the way the
story was told by Paul deiner of the
athletic the guy from the Patriots with
the logo on clearly blatantly recording
what was going on in the Bengals
sideline ostensibly because they wanted
to show what the advance scout does but
he watches bright during the game the
Bengals employee who noticed all this
was one row behind in the press box now
if it was any other team other than the
Patriots with that Bengals employee from
the instant that it was noticed have
said oh wait a minute there Jim you
can't do that very fair coin it was the
since it was the patriot us was there a
decision made to let this play out let's
go ahead and give them enough rope to
hang themselves so we can hammer the
Patriots and we can catch them again
that's one of the concerns I have but it
doesn't matter you don't get the benefit
of that when you have the reputation
that the Patriots have rightly earned in
Spygate wrongly earned into flight gate
in my opinion but either way the
reputation is what it is and I can't
help but wonder whether the bengals
employee would have sat back and let it
all play out if it was any team other
than the page you're right I do think
there's you know what do I want to say
people people want to throw the Patriots
under the bus and the NFL I mean there
certainly I have friends who just can't
wait to talk crap about
Patriot's or say something negative
about them whenever they get the
opportunity so there is a that feeling
or sense of feeling out there within the
NFL and I'm with you and hey you know
you know just just real quick because I
think we've hit all the major spots on
this topic too but I just brought you
brought it up when you said Ernie Adams
like hey Ernie Adams is a special
special brain just like Bill Belichick
and when I worked there for my 18 months
I'm not sure what the hell he did either
but he did special projects and I always
got the biggest kick out of Mike would
he be like this and when I got a kick in
the morning I had to go around and pass
out the schedule for the day and things
like that right because I was the
resident that way that's what I did
sorry for the phrase but that's what I
called myself yeah so but I used to get
a kick out of kind of walking into
Ernie's room Mike because I'd walk in
and I liked Ernie and I wanted to say hi
but it was always like this he's me had
the computer up and he he'd shut it and
he turned off his screen and like he
wasn't gonna let you see what project he
was working on with Bill which I always
got a kick out of I know that's a little
off-topic but I just thought it was you
know what you have no idea how on topic
it is you've just proven my point that's
how it would happen if it was gonna
happen
that's exactly how it would happen under
the auspices of Ernie Addams who's gonna
slam his computer shut even when someone
on his team walks into the office
because he doesn't want anybody to know
what he's up to
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports